Hey, what's going on? It's Bill Burr and
it's time for the Thursday afternoon.
Just before Friday. Monday morning
podcast. And I am just checking in on you.
A voice is still fucked
up. I got two more records,
people episode nine and number 10 where
a just broke number 10 we're almost
done.
Which means all freckles is then going
to be doing a bunch of spots around loss
of Congolese getting ready for
my European tour tour tour tour.
Yeah, yeah, yeah. Which
starts off in Dublin, Ireland,
Dublin, Ireland in a,
you know what's funny is I tried to
get on on July 31st it starts off and I
tried to get a, you know,
get a direct flight to the Emerald
Aisle and the a at this point because I
waited so long to get the
fucking tickets, um, you know,
which is a whole other story in
itself, you know what I mean?
Cause I'm going to take a vacation with
my wife afterwards and she was trying to
figure out where the fuck we were
going to go. And I was like, lady,
you better fucking figure out a place
soon cause this is gonna cost me a fortune
there. Um, so, uh,
turns out the out of lax,
the only two airlines,
it was air Lingus and um, uh,
what the fuck is it? Oh Jesus,
I already forgot the name of the what
the Hell is an Ethiopian Airlines?
Okay. Figure that one out.
I don't want to fly you the open airlines
and let some go into like, you know,
Ethiopia, Aer Lingus,
the Irish one. You know,
is that weird? Like if I'm
going to go to the Middle East,
I want to fly you, uh, that whatever
United Air Emirates. I don't,
it's just weird superstition that I have
like the people at Ethiopian Airlines
don't care cause they're flying to
Ireland. Does that make any sense?
It doesn't, that's just how scary
flying us. Like if I'm going to Poland,
I want a couple of Polish guy flying
it despite all the jokes about them.
Hey, how many Polish guys is it
take to fly a plane? A fucking,
hopefully two of them,
you know, that studied
all the shit they needed to know. So aer
Lingus was more expensive and I said,
well fuck it. I'm going to take the,
I don't even know if that's
the Irish one for some reason.
I think that's the one with the four
leaf clover or is it so you've got a
Leprechaun on the fucking
tailfin. Let me look this up.
Air Lingus latee every Irish guy's
giving me shit about my bad accent.
Like I give a fuck. All right.
Air Lingus images. Yeah,
there it is. Oh, it's a three leaf clover.
Put another fucking leaf on there yet.
[inaudible] make me feel a little better.
Oh Jesus. Is that the best
plane that got? Oh boy.
That looks like just some shit
from the early seventies all right,
let's look at Ethiopia.
Where Ethiopian air lines.
There is no food on this plane. Sorry.
Ethiopian Airlines.
Let's see what we got here. What do we
got here? I'm not going to lie to you.
Both of these planes still look
these. Neither one of these are very,
uh Oh look at this steward
assists. They look pretty fine.
They didn't have any stewards for the
Irish once. They probably all hammered.
Could I have any more stereotypes in this?
Um,
all right. They both live
professional. Who's kidding? Who?
You know what it is once you
travel outside of your own country,
you know what I mean? I fly
American Airlines. I fly United,
I fly shit that I've heard
of. I've always done that.
Except early on in my career
when I used to fly like fucking,
what the fuck was that one?
It was air something or other.
I felt like ATA, I mean you,
you flew on that fucking
airlines. It was like,
like the cabin to the
left of cockpit was open.
They were up there playing like
connect four and shit. It was,
it was really bad. I'm done. I'll tell
you. It was bad, you know? Um, no,
it was, it was just like,
it was still weirdest thing.
You'd been in an in an airport and just
feeling like you were in America and
then you'd get on ATA and you literally
felt like you were leaving a war torn
country.
Like you just look around like what the
fuck did all these extras come from?
Am I, am I in a my, in some fucking, uh,
George Clooney movie that's
some important George,
one of those selling arms
for some shit, you know,
a very important story that needed to be
tell w told we are filmmakers and this
is what we do. You know George,
they said this script was floating around
Hollywood for a while. Well, you know,
of good looking and I said I'm going
to do it. So it got made. Um, oh,
I got a call out fucking
Michael Rappaport. Okay, okay.
And you know,
you would think that I'm going to call
him out for the fact that his resting
face, you never heard of resting bitch
face. You know what his face looks like.
It looks like.
Do you remember that face Danny Ainge
would make after he got called for a foul?
That's what his resting
face looks like. All right.
Now I love this man except
what he talks about.
I've never seen somebody hate on
Boston sports the way he does. Right?
So he wrote some more
bullshit about Boston sports.
So I call him up breaking
his balls going through,
you know what you wrote us in true
laughing. We have a great fucking time.
He goes on the Internet like
some real housewife whore.
Right? And you know what
he said? He said, wow,
bill Burgess called me up
like a threatening make
blah blah blah and all this
fucking, hey, he's out.
He's tweeting like some Instagram
whore that's just trying to get fucking
followers. I don't understand it Michael,
if somebody send you
into this clip right now,
I even told them how fucking he
was being above Boston sports.
Nike. I guess he was freaking out that,
that the Celtics might get
Kevin Durant, which um,
you know, who's kidding deal
with the whole free agency game?
This is how it works as a fan.
Everybody doesn't like it unless
the free agent comes to their team.
That's basically it. But
at the end of the day,
even when they do come to your
team in the back of your head,
you know it's bullshit,
right?
I mean whatever. Yeah. Ut you're
getting fucked over by your team.
You want to go make some more money, fine.
But I'm talking when you're an elite
fucking player and you go to pile on
another fucking team. And I'm talking
as a Celtics Fan. When we did that in,
what was it?
Oh eight the only thing that made it
decent was that the Lakers had a bunch of
free agents. So we met in the
finals and it was sort of,
it was like the 80s in that those two
teams were in the finals back to back
years. But I mean it was, it was bullshit.
Like I don't look at the o eight
Celtics, like it was a blur.
We went from last place to first place.
We won the fucking thing and then we
played them again next year in the finals
and the referee's called 9,000 files on
us. And like 15 on the fucking Lakers.
And for some reason that was considered
a good game, seven to, I don't know,
but that's the NBA, you know, every once
in a while they have a mobbed up ref.
You know, Patrick Ewing
goes to the Knicks. Yeah.
You know, it's a
business. Um, but I think,
cause I,
I when I look at the NFL where
they got the parody there and uh,
all of a sudden, you know, the Seahawks
out of fucking nowhere can win one,
you know, fucking patriots
stunk for fucking ever.
All of a sudden we got good, you go up,
you go down these guys when those guys,
you know,
it's nice and fucking everybody kind of
has a chance now and that's been great.
Their ratings are better than ever
as far as I know. And I think the,
the route that the NBA is going is they
create these super teams and people hate
them so much that they watch
rooting for them to lose.
And um, I dunno, I liked it better.
I mean back in the day, like I said,
there was free agency
in that type of shit,
but it wasn't just the way it is now.
The amount of times where people pull
the old Johnny Damon where you fall,
I guess Daymond one with the red sox
and then like the next year or whatever,
he goes through the fucking Yankees. It's
just like what Jesus Christ. Can you,
can you ease your way around the fact
that it's just a business and it's all
about money, you know? Um, I dunno,
I actually don't know how Kevin Duran
really helps the warriors in a way.
You know,
they had their two guys that were
the guys and then he's coming in and,
and a lot of ways he's
at least number two,
depending on what you think
about the fucking, uh,
the fucking honor roll student there. Um,
I dunno. I know people say they
just want to win, but I don't,
I think egos get hurt when you know, you,
you used to get 25 points a game and
now you're down to like 21 or 19.
I Dunno. We'll see. What the fuck
happens. But uh, that sucked.
I was really hoping he was going to stay
in Oklahoma. I'm not gonna lie to you.
I was hoping that, uh, you know,
after last year where they
were up three games to one,
that they were going in
the off season to be like,
you know what the fuck happened? We
don't know how, we don't know how to win.
We don't know how to close somebody out.
And what I loved about
watching the warriors come
back against Oklahoma as much
as I was rooting for Oklahoma is
you got to watch a championship team
like w w what the warriors did
be in down three games to one.
Coming back in that series was,
it was fucking hilarious to me.
Like watching them, it was like,
you remember the horror movie?
Like they never changed their pace
when they were down. They didn't panic.
They just kept coming. You know,
it was like those old school
monster movies from the
80s where the fucking Jason
Guy, right, is just walking
in. The victim is running away.
He's the victims running
the monsters walking.
But the person running keeps
looking over their shoulder.
So they keep tripping
over logs and shit. Right.
So eventually the fucking deal with the
hatchet walks them down and puts him out
of their misery. That's what,
that's what fucking the
warriors did to Oklahoma. Yeah.
Geez, I'm such, was that too sophisticated
for you? You know, I got to tell you,
watching the warriors come back against
Oklahoma was like watching Friday the
13th part three. Oh Geez. Um,
so I've seen a bunch of teams do
that be better than the other team.
They just didn't know how to fucking
win. And then what happens is,
as a sports fan, you get to
watch them learn how to win.
You get to watch him. We'll share as a
faculty, that's what you get to watch.
Unless the best guy goes, you know what?
I don't feel like learning that's going
to go join the team that came back and
kicked our ass. I mean, can you
imagine if movies were like that?
Yeah.
All right. There's like the nerd
getting beat up by the bully. You know,
there's like five nerds getting beat
up by these five bullies, right?
It's five on five, right?
And then the third act is not the fucking
nerds figure out how to beat down the
bullies. One of the nerds
joints, the other bullies,
and then helps them go back and
beat up all his friends. I mean,
granted, I guess that kind of be
funny if you're a sick fuck like me,
but at the end of the day, I mean
I that kind of movie is that,
well,
maybe act two is that he goes to fucking
golden state and the next three is he
comes back and he has one of
those Lebron James type movies.
I don't fucking know. All
I know is a, you know,
I kinda got back into the NBA this year.
I started watching the Celtics and
that type of shit and that was a great
rivalry out west and now it's
no more. Did you hear what
Chiles Bark Barkley? Oh, it's
a great Boston named dude.
Fucking chows Barkley said
fucking Kevin Durant's a cheetah.
Not Cheating like Tom Brady. That
was bullshit. Cheek like Kevin Duran.
He's not on our team, so I'll hold
them to the fizz feet to the fire.
Um, uh,
no cheating like Jim or say,
okay.
He said that. Yeah, he's trying to
cheat his way to a championship.
He used the wrong word, but I
understand what he's saying. He's just,
he's just a fucking, yeah, he
just, he left the nerd table.
He CA's go to the bully table and then
he's going to come back and beat up the
notes. That'd be like, well, look, I'll
make, I'm a tough guy over here. Um,
isn't it amazing how much
taller Kevin Durant is than me?
And I'm still giving him shit.
That's the wonderful thing
about podcasting is you can
fucking talk shit within
the safety of your own living
room. All right, whatever.
I'm going to get off this fucking
topic, but, uh, I did in fact to confirm
Michael Rappaport's real housewife
tweet, by the way, is there anyone,
can somebody please Photoshop him into
one of those real housewife fucking
things?
We had a great conversation laughing our
balls off when we came to an agreement
in the end of it and
that Danny Ainge look in,
motherfucker goes on the Internet and he,
he tweets 180 letters or less about me.
By the way, I have to apologize for a,
I love Michael Rep for it. I, you know,
every time I see him,
I always feel like this is the last
time I'm ever gonna see him. You know,
there's just something about him,
even though he's younger than me,
he just moves around like he's in his
eighties. I think he has that disease,
you know that disease Brad Pitt had in
that movie where he was like a fucking
old baby. Whenever the fuck happened.
I don't know if that's what he wrote.
He reminds no, I was just a
fable. Right. Where's it called?
The fairy tale. Whatever. He fucking,
he's like that, you know, you know,
like when a fucking eight
year old looks like this 70,
whatever that disease
is called. [inaudible]
um,
I was going to see George
Meichin. That's not,
that wasn't the guy who was the
guy who played on Ohio state.
I went to Portland. That poor passed
it. The microfractures in his feet,
like he's playing in China
now. I can't remember.
I'm thinking is haven Moses. And I
only play for the Broncos in the 70s.
I want to say his name was George, wasn't
it? Okay. We got to look this up now.
How's State Ohio?
How State? Uh, Portland
micro fracture. Mike, not microbrewery.
Get the fuck out of my growth.
Breweries are the worst today.
Okay.
All right. What's his name?
What's his name? Greg [inaudible].
Michael Rappaport has Greg Oden disease.
Okay.
It does it like Greg Oden.
He got paid a ton of fucking money and
he didn't follow through if he got paid.
The, the, the, uh, national, uh,
podcasting association drafted him,
number one to come on to, into the
podcasting world to talk about sports,
thinking that he was going to be unfair.
No thinking that he was going
to be biased and fair. I came,
you fucking talk this morning. Oh my God,
I can't wait to do his
podcast again. You know,
who's kidding, who were both a couple of
real housewives? You know what I mean?
I think I'm slightly better looking
than him though. Slightly, you know,
and a little more mobile, you know,
I think I bring a lot more to a team.
I'm like Spike [inaudible], right? Utility
player him. I don't know what he is.
He's like a fucking Rappaport's
like a fucking, you know,
he's like dead d h You know,
his career's over, you know,
he can't touch his toes, so they
can't have him play first base.
He just sits on the bench seat
and sunflower seeds gets up three,
four times a game. Squinting
into the fucking Sun.
He just sneaks through the fences,
grounds out and do a double play.
Kills the rally, you know? But
he's got such a big contract,
they can't get rid of him.
Okay.
He's like Greg Luzinski. If you
went on a diet, I let him know.
No disrespect to Greg
Lissitzky. All right.
I don't know what the fuck I'm talking
about here. Oh, Formula One. Right.
Okay.
I needed to apologize. Um,
because when I was say,
when I watched the Austrian Grand Prix
that it was like fucking days of thought
and I said Louis Hamilton was
like the Tom Cruise, the upstart.
I add a completely wrong and I want to
thank everybody on Twitter that set me
straight so eloquently.
Hey, fuck stick. Um,
I guess Lewis Hamilton, he's been,
he's, he's won at three times.
He's a 31 fucking years old and he's
already won the a for me one championship
three times.
He won it in 2008 2014 and 2015
Nico Rosberg has never won.
So the reality is, is that
Nico was the Tom Cruise, right?
And Louis Hamilton is the val Kilmer.
He's the ice man. That's right.
Ice Man. I am dangerous.
And then Lewis Hamilton clicks his teeth
together for no fucking reason. Right?
They're all sweaty and shit. I Dunno.
All I know is the British Grand Prix is a,
is this fucking ah, is this
Sunday and that dude toto,
I swear to God, that's his fucking nick.
All I want to do when I wake up in the
morning is not, see the team crash.
Um, sat down with them. It was
just like, listen, alright,
right. Stop fucking driving into each
other mate. Whatever the fuck he said.
I don't know where he's from. I think
he's just, I think he is from Austria.
Who knows. I'm new to this sport and
I just like throwing up shit as fact.
You know what I mean? And why would I,
why would I actually waste the time to
read up on this sport when I can just
make big fucking statements and people
on Twitter will correct me anyways,
you know, then I don't have to look
it up. All I gotta do is just scroll,
you know, that's why these kids are
so fucking dumb today. You know,
they don't read books the way I
used to, you know, three hours in,
I'm 17 pages in my fucking a ds
off the fucking chart. Right.
Sitting there reading about Tom
Sawyer. You don't think about,
I dunno what you know the Queen Mary God
knows whatever was said in that fucking
book that made me think of
something else. Apples houses,
some sort of arsenic in there.
And how many apples would you have to
do eat to actually poison yourself?
You know, eat so many fucking
apples. What do you think?
There's arsenic assumption, you
know the apple, some sort of poison.
I can't remember what, but if
you ate enough of them, right,
you'd actually die in that. Somebody would
actually bet to say eulogy. You know,
an apple a day does in fact
keep the doctor away. But a,
you know, eat 42 of them. You're
gonna fucking die. But you know what?
He died the fruity. Whoa. Um,
anyways, let's, let's read some of the
fucking horse shit here for this week.
Let's read some of the
advertising. Shall We? Is this,
it is just a simple safe. What
does that sound like? Bad food.
All right. No, it isn't simple. Safe.
All right. Hallux Helix. You're unique.
You don't waste, you don't
walk like everyone else talk
like everyone else talk,
walk, shoot. Shit that sounded
like doing that Marine Corps.
I'm going to teach you how
to walk. Talk to Chad Parker.
You know I've turned my core. All
right. You're unique, everybody.
You don't walk like everyone else
talk like everyone else are three like
everyone else.
So why is your mattress your so why is
your mattresses so why is your mattress
Jenny spelled mattress.
Okay,
well how do you spell mistress? So why
is your mattress one size fits all? Gee,
I don't know.
I Dunno cause you fucking cause it fits
because a truly customized mattress will
cost you five or 10,000
bucks. Ah, that's the reason.
Who the fuck has the money to do that?
They should get audited immediately.
Do you know I was watching one of those
Barrett Jacksons one time and they had
one of those,
those GM that Pereda Prague
progress fucking elephant van there.
Somebody spent four point $1 million on
that fucking thing and was excited they
got a good deal. You know what I mean?
That guy either needs to get audited or
he has his wife bound and gagged in a
fucking closet. How you
pull the, hey, hey honey,
look what I spent $4 million on a giant
fucking toaster that you can drive.
Okay.
What do you mean? Why did
I do that? Oh, go. I liked,
I thought it was a good
deal. Fuck you lady. Right?
What are these things called? GM Parade.
This is still the advertising
parade of progress.
I used to know what these things
were called. Parade a progress image.
The GM Futurliner looked that
fucking thing up. I mean, granted,
it's kind of cool, but it is,
it's like an easy bake oven that you can
drive and somebody paid four point $1
million for that fucking thing,
you know? And all I said,
all I could think was what was he doing
in 2008 when the fucking economy crashed
other than doing fucking cartwheels out
the back door of whatever fucking bank
he worked at. Oh bill was that
social commentary. You freckled cut?
Just shut up and read the advertising.
All right, up. Here we go.
Hello everybody. Helix. I'm going to
read this like a fucking yoga instructor.
You're unique. You don't walk like
anyone else. Talk like anyone else,
they're asleep like anyone else. So
why is your mattress one size fits all?
Because they truly customize mattress
will cost you five to 10,000 bucks.
And how many starving
children could that feed?
40 50 million for only half a cent a day.
Somehow you can give somebody three
square meals on Ethiopian Airlines.
All right, for cuss your five
to 10,000 bucks until now.
So go to hellickson.sleep.com answer a
few simple questions and they'll run a 3d
biomechanical model of your body through
the [inaudible] proprietary algorithms
they've developed it.
Doesn't that sound like a bunch of
bullshit January proprietary algorithms?
I can't say it to most of the good a.
They developed with the help of the
world's leading Aragon nomics and
biomechanics experts. The results,
the most comfortable mattress
you've ever slept on.
Helix customers.
How Alex report a 30% improvement in
overall sleep quality. And for couples,
they customize each each
side of the mattress. Oh,
that's great.
Your mattress arrives at your door in
about a week and shipping is 100% free.
That's why everyone from GQ magazine
to Forbes aren't those the same people.
You get to the top of your bank and
then all of a sudden you're like,
I'm going to have it yet.
And fucking wavy brown hair with the
fucking Rolex are all talking about helic
sleep. You have 100 nights to try
it out. And if you don't love it,
they'll pick it up for free
and give you 100% refund.
No questions asked. Go
to hell. You know what?
A lot of homeless people are gonna be
getting a good nights then cause there's
no fucking way you can resell that.
Kenya or Kenya. I don't fucking know.
Alright, I'm just dump it on a sidewalk.
Go to helix, sleep.com/bar
and get $50 off your order.
That's helic sleep.com/burr. Hey,
he likes sleep.com/burb
all right, and lastly,
but certainly not leastly. Uh,
what's that road friend? Zip
[inaudible] are you hiring?
Do you know where to post your
job to find the best candidates?
Posting your job in one place isn't enough
to find quality candidates. Come on,
wake up. Do you want to
find the perfect hire?
You need to post your job to all the
top job sites and you can do it now.
All right. With Zip
cruda.com you can post your job
to a hundred plus job sites,
including social media networks
like Facebook and Twitter,
all with a single click.
Find candidates in any city
or industry nationwide.
Just post once and watch your
qualified candidates roll into zip.
Okay. Crude ares, easy to use. Interface.
No juggling emails or calls to your
office. Quickly screen candidates.
Rate them. Look at the tits on her
and hire the right person fast.
Find out why zip.
Okay.
Recruiter has been used by 800,000
businesses and right now listeners can try
Zyban or I am recruited for free by
going to ziprecruiter.com/bar that's
ziprecruiter.com/bro.
One more time. Go to zip
[inaudible] dot com slash
[inaudible] all right,
there we go. There we go. To the
perfect place that perfectly takes. Um,
all right, so once again, my a my
European tour, boop, boop, boop.
My Euro peon mother
fucking fucking tour. Oh,
I'm good. I am going to fucking,
I am so excited about this tour.
All right. I'm so excited.
I love going to Europe.
I love being everything that they
want me to be. Okay. I'm sorry.
I'm not going to be fat on this one cause
I've been hitting the elliptical there
, but I am going to be,
I'm going to go over there,
right and I'm going to talk to them
about the finer points of Donald Trump.
That's what I want to do.
Especially in Scotland where they had
the nerve to call our fucking orange
headed cunt of fucking
orange headed country.
You got a lot of fucking nerve Scotland
calling an orange headed content,
orange handed content. Amy, why
don't you look around your country.
There's plenty of orange headed
cops there. All right. We are,
we have very few here.
Every once in a while they
went for president when
they're in between seasons of
their reality show. Okay.
What's great about our country is
everybody truly does get a chance.
Unlike your countries. I have no
fucking idea what's going on over there.
Evidently, England decided to not
be part of the European Union.
Is that what happened? I
love how like as an American,
I'm supposed to know this shit,
a union that I'm not into. I,
I understand what's going on over there.
The banks are sewing up
all your fucking countries.
It's like when you fucking
buy a a a Co op, you know,
versus a condo. You buy a Condo,
the person next to you can be a
fucking junkie who gives a shit.
You still got your condo. But
if you're in a co op playoffs,
if you're in a co-op, this
is the deal. What you're,
you're not buying an apartment.
What you're doing is you're
buying shares in the building,
but now you're tied in with the whole
building. So basically if your neighbors,
enough of your neighbors
go bankrupt and the whole,
the whole building goes under,
you lose your shares and you either have
to move out of your apartment or you go
back to renting it and you're like, wait
a minute, I thought I bought it. No,
no, no sir. You bought
shares in the building.
You paid your way, but these other
kinds didn't. And because they didn't,
you go down to the bottom
of the lagoon with them.
That to me is what the European Union
is, right? And that's what banks want,
right? And they just fucking
bankrupt them. And, uh,
I don't know what the fuck they do.
They play that little fucking game.
They buy low and then they
fucking go high. And I'll fuck,
could they pull the money
out and everybody falls in
their fucking ass and then
they got another castle. You know? I
think that that's how the economy works,
right? And it's all run
by shapeshifters. Okay.
Just shit like that. You know what I mean?
Especially when I'm in London and
those stupid fucking critics show up,
Ugh, fucking guys, critics are the
fucking worse. There's nothing you can do.
There's no show that you can have that
they're not going to rip the shit out of
it. It's just fucking hilarious to
me. It's like I don't need critics.
All right. If I wanted to feel bad about
having a good show, I just call my mom.
I don't fucking need you to be doing
our job. You all right? Whatever.
All right. July 31st
everybody. Dublin, Ireland.
Alright, then August 1st I'm in
Belfast. I've never been there. Belfast,
Ireland, the fuck is his
Belfast UK. All right.
It's Ireland. I think it's about time
England got the fuck out of there.
Um, can you imagine saying that
as American seriously, you know,
is we are putting up cheesecake
factories in the Middle East. All right.
August 1st, Belfast UK.
Um, August 2nd, I'm in
Galway, Ireland. Uh,
which is way out on the west coast and
evidently the closest airport is like a
fucking hour away from it. So I don't
understand what this is. This is,
it seems like, should I ruin it?
And actually fucking
Google some pictures of it.
Call Away Ireland. Let's see. We got here.
Oh my God. Jesus Christ. I knew
it. I know. This is going to be,
what are these fucking
a, which is a warlock,
one of those fucking movies
type cities. Harry Potter.
Look at this fucking place. Oh my God.
I'm only spending a day there.
Okay.
Wow. Look at the fucking castles.
Holy Shit.
Right?
I'm going to drive in there, do the show,
and then I got to drive right
back so I can make my flight.
What the fuck am I
going? Did I fuck it up?
Where am I going next? Alright,
I'm go to a [inaudible],
then I fly to a Bristol, uh,
England and then Manchester, England, the,
a sober, sophisticated Manchester.
I'm thinking that's going
to be a nice mellow crowd.
Fucking loaded ticks. Um, that's what
I'm anticipating in Manchester. I,
I'm anticipating they're going to be a
bunch of fucking lunatics, which is a,
which is fine by me. I, um, I
grew up Massachusetts, you know,
um, London, England, August 5th and
August 6th with the country critics. Uh,
August 7th, I'll be in
Amsterdam and then August 8th,
I will be in Edinburgh, uh, for two shows.
All right. So we got a
late show too. Okay. Um,
then I've got a couple days off where
I'll be hanging out with other orange
headed consts like myself. And
then August 11th, I'm in Germany,
Cologne, Germany, bodywash, Germany.
Then August 12th, I'm in Antwerp,
Belgium. Oh look at this.
August 27th, I'm in Reno, Reno, Nevada,
Reno, Nevada.
And at that point we will be only a
couple of months away from that fucking
kitchen. T V square headed, fucking safe,
crazy eyes smiling psycho from becoming
the next fucking president of the United
States. Oh, that's
going to be a rough one.
Watching all these ladies
saying how fucking,
what an important date is for women.
I guess it will be because a woman
will be elected president is just my
prediction here. All right.
But uh, Jesus Christ couldn't,
we have gotten one that didn't
have 58 pending fucking felonies.
That's not a red flag. Anybody, you know,
I don't know. What are you going to do?
Those are our choices. I don't know why.
A fucking maniac who, you know,
doesn't know how to use email properly.
You know, sending out
secrets to a friends.
Um, and then some fucking
guy who's a, I dunno,
who really should just
be a carnival barker.
I feel like Trump should just standing
next to some impossible game to win.
Talking about how it's the
greatest game ever. You know,
who's he hits on underage chicks.
Um, I don't know. That's just, just,
just the opinions of somebody who, uh,
can't pronounce words while he reads out
loud what he thought. He say that Cleo,
that c a, that's the podcast here for
this, uh, this Thursday afternoon,
um,
could sell. Oh, I, you know what,
somebody please send me a fucking
whatever you see a Photoshop picture of
fucking Rappaport's face on Danny Angel's
body when he played for the Celtics.
I really want to see that today.
You can do whatever the fuck
you want to do with my head.
You know, I don't give a fuck. Um,
that's it. All right. I got
to go hit the elliptical.
So I'm not a fucking fat fuck at
the end of this writing season here.
Congratulations to Kevin Durant. Um,
okay.
On your next, uh, on your, on your
first championship rink. You know,
I want to put together a standup
tour like that. You know what I mean?
I want to join like the, uh, like
if Louis C K and Dave Chappelle,
Dave Chappelle, we're doing like a standup
tour. I'd somehow like, I not know.
I don't know. I do like
their next standup specials.
I'll splice part of my hour
in there and get credit.
Uh, all right, that's it. Um, you guys
have a great weekend. You conscious
and I'll, uh, I'll talk to you on
Monday. Enjoy the music and, uh,
another half hour of Monday morning
podcast back from yesteryear.
[inaudible]
Nah, go to bed. [inaudible]
my brain. [inaudible]
t c is
so to [inaudible]
[inaudible]
with die. Geez.
Hey, what's going on?
Is this still press and this is the
Monday morning podcast that I'm actually
doing from my [inaudible] home
phone rather than my cell phone.
I finally figured out how to call
in this, this, this, this, my space.
Uh, fucking Jesus Christ. I'm having
one of those weeks. All right.
I just talk.
I just babbled for 12 minutes and decided
that I didn't like it and now I have
to fucking start all over
again. I don't want to do this.
I don't want to do this.
You think I want to do this?
I don't want to fucking do this. You know,
sometimes in life you gotta do what
you got. Yeah. You the only, yeah,
these fucking podcast, man. Yeah. How
long these things take? Seven weeks.
I get on here, you know, I just babble.
It's fucking gold. Just half hour,
just running my goddamn mouth
out. And you have to think,
and then there's other times it's, it's
just, it's like shoveling wet snow.
And you know what?
I'm fucking sticking this one out
cause I'm not gonna start over again.
Eight sometimes. You know what?
Sometimes you just not that funny.
You fucking minds broken up
or whatever. I don't know.
Let's just get down to goddamn brass tax
here and I'll let you know what I got
going on. All right. My name is
Bill Barr. This is my myspace page.
This is my Monday morning podcast. I
do one of these every goddamn week.
Okay. Try to get people a nice laugh to
start off the fucking weeks. And a I,
we start off in a good mood and then I
ended up getting frustrated with my own
ineptness and then I ended
up just fucking, I dunno,
I end up snapping and I
say fuck a lot. All right.
And uh, okay, let's get on with people
ask me questions. I answer them.
Look at me. I'm just, you know,
I'm just blowing through this.
Just blowing through the explanations.
I usually take my time and explain this.
You know what this is like,
you ever like break your arm or
something and you go to school.
The next day instance, the first kid
goes, hey man, what happened to your arm?
Right? And you give them every
last fucking detail. Okay.
But then by the time you've told the
fucking story to like the 12th person,
by the time the 13th person comes up to
you, you're like, I fucking fell down.
All right with the fucking
thing happened. You know,
that's the mindset I'm in
right now as I do this podcast.
After just blowing 12 minutes of
your rising time on my home phone,
I'm all right. Here we go. Let's get
down with this shit. Hey, let's get it.
Get on with it.
I put up a new video because I am
desperately trying to get myself to become
part of the new millennium. Um,
it's right underneath the podcast.
If you look there,
you'll see a very blurry,
very blurry me in a Winnipeg jets shirt,
by the way, because I'm old school,
old school hooky. Um,
let's meet at the punchline in Atlanta
and before you watch the video,
I just want to give you a little
backstory of what happened. Uh,
I was actually a,
it was Thursday night and a couple of
weeks ago and it's one of my favorite
clubs now. I was just having one of
these awesome sets where I was, uh,
I was really open and free and everything
was just flowing as opposed to this
podcast, which feels very
arduous, free work like that.
I used that word correctly.
What the fuck is quest love learning
those fucking lime green pants and just
realized that I'm, anyways, I
was having one of these, um,
one of these just, you know,
really open just great sets and I was
about 12 minutes and everybody was
laughing. Everybody's having a good
time. I was having a good time,
but for some reason there was this lady
in the crowd and it wasn't enough that
she felt my jokes were funny.
She was somehow agreeing with the
things that I was saying on stage.
So rather than laughing
at the end of every joke,
you know, when the punchline
came out, instead of laughing,
she would just yell out
Sankyo after every joke,
you know, the rest of the crowd was,
would be laughing and then I would just
hear this woman's voice over everybody.
Hey Yo.
So this video picks up about
12 minutes into my set.
She's already yelled saying Geo like
fucking 12 times. And I feel annoying.
That is with me saying that to you.
Just imagine being onstage
trying to keep the crowd,
trying to keep the fucking plate spinning
and somebody keeps yelling that shit
out.
So she yells it out for I guess basically
the sixth time and that's when I
finally snapped. But I
snapped in a good way.
I was proud of myself where I didn't
shop her head off and be overly mean.
It was kind of mean, but it
was definitely funny. And, um,
I just want to let you guys know I'm,
I'm going to start taping all
my sets because, uh, you know,
I riff a lot and I ended up, you know,
missing a lot of good lines that I could
keep in my act and also random shit
happens and I'm going to start posting
some of the random shit that, that, uh,
happens up here. Um,
unless people really start to enjoy these
and then they come out to my shows and
then they deliberately
try to yell out something,
which is always the risk of it.
But basically I like doing this kind of
thing because I want to give you guys
some new, some new laughs without
having to burn any material.
You know what I mean? I mean,
I'm not treading Reznor here.
I can't just give away my
new hour for free. You know,
like he can, I'm jealous musicians, right?
They can just fucking put the
goddamn music out for free now.
And then everybody comes to their
shows and when they know all the words,
they get to sing along. So it's
different than he can go. You know,
we're going to break it down. Detroit,
we're going to break it down here, right?
And then he,
then he slows the fucking song down and
then everybody go whatever things the
music level down and everybody sings
along. You can't do that with jokes.
Maybe if I started singing
my jokes, maybe I'll do that.
I'll come with a fucking
Ukulele on stage, you know,
I could fucking sing. That's
why guitar racks blow up,
man telling you fucking telling you.
I heard about some kid in
Massachusetts. He's a kid,
he's been putting funny songs up on
Youtube for the last year and he just sold
out the comedy connection. It's like
17 fucking years old, you know, long.
It took me to sell at
the comedy connection. 15
fucking years telling jokes.
You know why? Because I don't sing.
I would just sing my God damn jokes.
What's the deal with labs? Everybody?
If I would just do that, if I would
just do that, I don't know you.
I don't know what would happen. You
know something you always want to think,
you know, if I just did
that, then I'd be here.
You never think of all
the failed guitar racks.
You know the ones that you guys don't
see. You just see the successful ones.
You know the ones with their half hour
specials, the ones selling up theaters.
All right? You don't see the ones that
opened for me when I go to Portland,
Oregon, or at least when I did back
in the day, way back in the day,
10 years ago,
he's played a club called Harvey's and
all I remember was the walls were green
and the guy used to, he used
to give the whole show away,
which basically he would
have telemarketers call
people up and just be like,
Hey, guess what? You've won tickets to it.
You went for free tickets to a comedy
show. And the people would be like,
Holy Shit, how the fuck did I win?
Knows I didn't even enter the contest,
you know? Well,
you won them because a comedy was
not selling well 10 years ago.
So these to give away, basically
they've given away the show.
He'd walked into this fucking
place. It'd be a Tuesday, you know,
I'd tell Mosey and, and I'm
thinking, all right, the Tuesday,
it'll be half full. No one knows who
the fuck I am. I lean on the Mike stand,
I'll riff, I'll get some new jokes.
And you would walk in there and you
would think that Springsteen was going to
come off.
It was jam packed 400 fucking drunk ass
people who didn't know me and did not
give a shit whether the
show was good or not really,
because they already felt like they
had already won. They got free tickets.
So you would go up there and it
would just be, it'd be a fucking zoo.
It would be an absolute zoo. And,
uh, a lot of lumberjacks that,
that was the vibe I got. You know,
Oregon has a lot of trees and you'd
be down there in Portland and you'd be
thinking, all right, it's very crunchy,
very sort of a progressive. But,
uh, you know, those cuts
don't come out to shows.
The lumberjacks would come out,
they'd be screaming and yelling and eating
burgers that would have fried eggs on
the top of them. And, uh, and it sucked.
And I don't even know why
I'm talking about this.
I already forgot I spaced halfway
through that fucking story because, um,
cause that's the mindset I'm
in this week. I, you know,
is I got a zillion fucking
things I gotta take care of.
Cause I'm on my way to Pittsburgh this
week and I'm flying in a day early, uh,
to do, um,
I'm doing a lot of radio this week cause
I'm going to try to sell that fucking
place out. I want to be on a wd
VIII with Randy Bowman this week.
Um, and if I had any fucking brains, I
would've looked that up and giving you a,
I don't know, it's 100 point something.
I think if you live in Pittsburgh,
you can listen to me and I'll be young
and say, you listen to me in the morning,
Wednesday morning, Thursday
morning and Friday morning,
and then you come out on the
weekend, you check out my show.
Just a little love ago. I'd just
come onto my goddamn show. Okay.
I don't know fucking, I don't
want to tell you. Um, please,
I don't want to stand there alone.
I care that that mall is
the most depressing fucking
mall in America for those
of you who've never been to it.
That Pittsburgh Improv is in
a mall called the stacks. Um,
why did they call it
the stacks? Basically?
Because I guess the mall
used to be a steel mill.
Okay.
When we used to have industry in this
country before they started telling us
that everything was too expensive to
make in this country. So they had to,
you know,
ship it to a third world country and
have some eight-year-old killed kid make
fucking spittoons or
whatever the fuck it is.
You make an a goddamn steel steel mill,
right. Rather than being like, no.
All Americans are involved with unions
and they want health insurance and they
want to get paid for their work.
They, they, they just, they,
they just fucking picked up and
left. But this is what they did.
They knocked down the
factory, but they, uh,
they kept the stacks.
Okay.
Just to remind you that, that people,
uh, you know, there's, this reminded me,
might even be a Poulter guys. You
know, you move the headstones,
but you didn't move the bodies.
That's what they did at that
mall. They moved the factory,
but they left the smoke stacks.
That's what they did to remind you that
hardworking Americans used to have jobs
there and they could support
their families and they
made shit out of steel that
other Americans would then buy, okay?
And the dollar was worth something,
but they got rid of all that.
They shifted somewhere else and in
its wake they left fucking cheesecake
factory's lucky jeans and the
fucking cold stone creamery.
Okay?
But in tribute to all those
people that they fucked over,
they left the chimneys. Isn't that nice?
A little nod to the past and
now they're fucking kids.
What are they doing? What
are they? Where do they work?
You haven't noticed that when you
meet people and they come up to you,
you ask them what the fuck they
do? You don't. You can't eat.
You don't even know what it is. What
do you do? I worked in a steel mill,
okay. You work in a mill, there's
steel there and you work there.
So you work with steel in a mill. I get
that. I understand what that job is.
What do you do? I'm the
Milkman. Okay. You're a man.
There's milk and you fucking deliberate,
man. You're the milk man. I get it.
I fucking get it.
You realize how many jobs there are
that people actually understand what the
fuck it is you do now. There's very
few left. I'm a mailman. I'm a man.
I deliver mail. I'm the fucking
mail man. Back then they was simple,
simple fucking names. All right.
I'm a silver Smith. All
right? Smith meaning, uh,
like to, to hit with a hammer like
smite. And I would do it with silver.
A fucking silversmith. All
right. There wasn't any, the uh,
the regional director of the
fucking, you know, so I can't even,
I can't even give you an
example of somebody's job.
I'm trying to think of the,
the, all these computer.
I sit in a cubicle and make
somebody else's dream happen.
I'm telling you right now, man, it's
just sitting in a fucking cubicle.
Just do something rebellious today.
Just take one of the
screws out of your fake.
I don't really have an office wall that
they put in front of you to make you
feel like you have half an office.
But the reality is they don't want
you looking at other people. You know,
I think I've talked about this before.
Do you guys ever see that movie,
the apartment starring a Jack Lemon?
If you see the beginning of that movie,
that's what the cubicle area used to
look like. You still had a sea of people,
you know,
slugging away looking like a bunch of
goddamn salmon swimming upstream with
fucking typewriters in front of them.
But they didn't have walls around them
like they were on punishment. You know,
you could look at the person
next to you shoot the shit,
but then somewhere along the line
they're like, oh, the fucking talking.
We can't have them looking at themselves.
They're literally treating you like
children. It's just, I don't know,
it's just fucking, it just blows my
mind. You know what I mean? I, I,
I'd rather sell drugs. All right.
Um, so anyways, this is the, yeah,
this is the Monday
morning podcast and, uh,
people send me questions
if you new to my page,
if you haven't defected
to fucking Facebook,
like the fact that you
are, you know what I mean?
I love these people go
into Facebook now, like,
like the same herd of assholes that
went from Friendster to my space.
Isn't, isn't gonna, you know, they're not
going to eventually end up over there.
Like there's not going to be a bunch
of spam about ringtones and a bunch of
whores with the bud cracks and
their titties hanging out, you know,
sending you generic emails trying to
make it seem like they didn't send it to
everybody else,
but you realize that they did because
rather than calling you by your name,
it just says, Hey, you love your page
by the way.
I'm the fucking Nokia phone whore
the month or whatever the hell they,
you know, all those stupid beauty
contest things that they go to when, um,
I'm sticking it out here, man. All right.
And all you guys who all going over to
Facebook, you know what you're like,
you like the, you ever see that movie,
that titanic where as those guys,
you know who fucking jumped in into the
rafts all by themselves, those self,
his sons of bitches who
were actually smart,
who listened to that voice that
says I need to fucking survive.
Well maybe they are smart, then
maybe they realize that my space,
maybe my space is a
sinking ship. You know,
I don't know. That'd be
actually kind of funny.
No it wouldn't because they've
already made their money off it.
Rupert Murdoch already brought about
the same in $1 billion already fucking
content. Um, all right, I
answered questions here.
I'm really just babbling here. Um, I
answered questions here every week.
People send me questions. Um, I try to
answer them to the best of my ability.
And uh, here we go. Here are the,
are the podcast for the week.
Um, oh and by the way,
when you watch my video,
could you please send me a comment
if you like it or whatever.
Cause that's like a new thing
that I really want to start doing.
Just putting some random moments up
there like that. Um, so, so let me,
let me know. Let me know what you think.
Okay. Question number one. Hey Bill,
which one was better?
Mike Richters insane.
Save against Pavelle bewray that's
how you saying Pablo Obra number.
Don't want to say these
Russian guys names is insane.
Save against his penalty
shot or Patrick Wall.
Mike Vernon going at its center rights.
I'm definitely going to say Mike
Richter just because, uh, that was,
that was one of the best
years ever in hockey.
That was like 2004 when the red sox
finally wanted to watch the ranges.
Finally win the cup and everybody go
crazy. That was just an amazing moment.
And uh, the Patrick Wa my burning
thin, you know, I don't know.
It's, it was, you know,
it was a great fight.
It's great to see Patrick
while loose. But you know,
that other one was for the Stanley Cup.
And I remember watching that in
1994 and watching the ranges went.
And I remember thinking clearly that's
what it's going to be like when the red
sox,
that they ever get their heads out of
their asses and they finally fucking win
one. That that's going to
be what it's like. So a,
I was living vicariously and for some
reason I didn't hate the Rangers for the
simple fact that I was not old
enough when the rangers last time,
the range is Bruins rivalry was
great, which was back in the 70s.
I was still just a,
a just a little lad with a big Motha
fucking red hair looking like that dude
Jody on a family affair. All right.
And that's why I became a comedian
because that's who the fuck I look like.
And I got the shit kicked out of me. Um,
all right, question number two, Bill.
How the hell does Paris Hilton
keep getting movie roles? Well,
I actually thought about this one.
And I think the reason that she
keeps getting movie roles is because,
uh, not to be crude, but, uh,
she's not afraid to show the clam,
you know, and, uh, I think, uh,
you know, I think that's how,
that's how you gotta deal
with sometimes as a woman,
you gotta you gotta just every once in
a while you just gotta take your pussy
out, you know, and, uh, I don't
think there's anything wrong with it.
Sharon Stone did it.
Sharon Stone was, you know,
meandering around all these
fucking B movies. She, you know,
she had it halfway decent roll and
some sort of Schwartzenegger movie,
but it wasn't until she showed
the clam that people's, you know,
sat up and took notice.
Next thing you know,
she's in that movie casino and
delivered one of the best performances.
I thought she, she, she was,
she nominated for an Oscar.
She should have won one that year.
But that's when showing the clam kind
of hurt her because all the other women
resented her. You know what I mean?
They thought that she was a whore
rather than she did what she had to do.
And I don't understand why
women get upset when that like,
you know, you're treating
me like a a, you know,
like a sexual object and it's
like you are a sexual object.
You know what I mean? That's
like you. I, I'm like,
oh you're just fucking using me
cause I can pick up heavy shit.
I can pick up.
I mean not extra heavy shit but
heavier shit cause I'm a guy,
you know,
that's where Hillary Clinton fucked up
her campaign when she fucking put on the
pants suit, you know,
she should have sexted up a little vamped
it up. God gave you titties, use them,
show little cleavage, you know what I
mean? That's what she should've done.
And people, you know, if you think
that's still, that's stupid. You know,
guys don't get elected
because of their brains.
Bill Clinton got elected because he played
the saxophone on fucking Arsenio Hall
and when our CTO came in
to do the black handshake,
somehow Bill Clinton was able to do
it without fucking breaking his wrist.
And I think that right there was, when
was, when that was the turning of it.
What else did he do? We just sat there
smiling with his mouth open going,
Jane's American wants change.
He didn't say anything.
He played the fucking saxophone.
So if you're a woman, you know,
show little titty, share a
little titty, that's all.
That's all I could tell you. Oh
God, I'm so ignorant. All right. Uh,
question number three, uh, Bill, uh,
[inaudible]. What the fuck is this one?
Um, all right, thanks for
answering my questions.
Or this is an up and coming comedian.
I competed in a funniest person
contest in a city that I will not,
I'm not gonna name cause I don't
get this person in trouble.
Just in case one of my 14 listeners
is the club owner of that. Anyways,
the owner said that he would not hire
any of the comedians to work for any of
the clubs because we were too vulgar.
The crazy thing is I noticed
that it was an older crowd,
but I was being stubborn and
decided to do my normal routine,
which was some dirty jokes. In your
opinion, do you think you're selling out?
If you adjust your comedic style to
get into the big corporate clubs?
Um, okay. Um, all right. I
know what you're saying here.
I've done the same thing. Um, I've
looked out in the crowd going,
okay, this is what I want to
talk about. You look at them,
you judge them and you go, well,
I'm going to be eating my balls,
at least 40% of my set if I
stick with what I want to do.
And um, yeah,
when you 100% adjust your
act, you yeah. You definitely,
yeah. You feel dirty, you know, not, not
them, not to use a pun there, but yeah.
You don't feel good. But, uh,
it isn't 100% selling out
if you know, I don't know.
It's one of those weird things
where it's your own judgment call.
You know what I mean? Because I used
to do those NACA things for the,
for those of you who aren't comedians
here, they have these things every year.
Um, these, these national
showcases for college gigs.
And when I used to showcase for them, I
would go up and I would just do my act,
you know, and I remember one year,
something that was going on in my app
was the first time I got, you know,
an HIV test and I was talking
about the fear of it, which is,
and it's really not a joke that you
want to do on a college showcase.
You just want to do you happy shit. And
I did. And I was like, fuck dead man,
I'm fucking selling out.
So I went up there and I did
my shit and you know what,
I got zero schools and I just got people,
they kept coming up to me and going,
we think you're hilarious. You know,
they kept getting the whole world,
who was up to me, I book you but I
can't because of blah, blah, blah, blah,
blah. And what I learned was sometimes
you got to play the game a little bit.
So what I would then do was
I would go up, after that,
I would go up into a squeaky clean
set. Then I would book the colleges.
And then when I went to the colleges,
I would actually then do my act and
then do the shit that I wanted to talk
about. So in a weird way,
I actually won cause I got the money and
I still got to do what I wanted to do.
And I got people to hear the material,
more people to hear the material that
I want them to hear. I just had to be,
uh, I had a wore myself out, you know,
I had to put it on the Tuxedo for
like fucking five, six minutes. Jesus,
he just brought up a really bad fucking
memory. Um, no, but dude, I would say,
you know, on your way up.
Yeah. Nobody wants, you know,
a lot of headliners don't want to
go on in front of a guy who kills.
And they also don't want to go on in
front of a guy who's, you know, if you,
if you're being a little dirty,
that gives them an excuse
to kind of be like,
not just say that I can't follow
this guy. There'll be like, oh,
he's just being dirty. So, uh, yeah,
play the game a little bit. You know,
you play the game a little bit and
then as people get to know who you are,
you get way more leeway
and eventually, uh,
you get to do your thing. You know
what I mean? It's one of those things.
You gotta be like a tree, you know,
Ben, but don't break, you know, I dunno.
Do whatever the fuck you want to
do, but you know, uh, I don't know.
That's my 2 cents. I don't fucking know.
I have no confidence
in my goddamn opinion,
so I don't know even know why you
people ask me questions. All right.
Question number four. Uh, Bill,
have you been approached about doing
any shows since your skits on Chappelle?
Um, yeah, catch one every year and
I try to get them on TV. But, um,
for those of you who always ask me, how
come you don't have your own TV show?
Because it's really hard.
It's all I can tell you. Okay.
It's very hard to get a show on
TV because believe it or not,
a lot of people want to get a show on
television because you can make a lot of
money. So, uh, I keep getting
closer. Keep getting closer.
Um, hey bill, what do you think
about Shaq's rap about Coby?
Who was the bigger d bag
and this never ending saga?
I think Shaq was just fucking
around. I thought he was joking,
but he wasn't joking, but he was
joking. You know what I mean? I mean,
if somebody gets arrested for a potential
rape and they bring my name up during
it, you know, um,
I think I have the license
to give him shit for awhile.
If I'm in a club and
I want to fucking, uh,
make fun of him a little bit. Yeah, I
dunno. I just looked at chef's face.
I thought he was clearly joking around
and it was so over the top. Colby had,
how's my ass taste? I mean, I dunno.
How does it take shack? I don't know.
Like you've been running full
court for the last 15 years.
What a disgusting question.
All right. Uh, number five.
We got a lot of questions this week
and we try to blow through them. Um,
but I went to the Tempe Improv,
saw this comic. He was good,
but the opening Yak was
killing it. He was so funny.
Do you ever get worried or stressed that
your opener's going to be more funny
than you? Um, is there any sort of process
you go through picking your opener?
Am I worried about them being more
funny? Uh, well yeah. No I'm not. I'm,
they're fucking middle ex
for a reason. All right.
If you can't follow a middle act
and you're, you're not a headliner.
I've definitely had some funny
guys on in front of me. Um,
but I think that's a good
thing. You know what I mean?
You don't want to be sparring
with somebody who sucks
because then you're going
to end up sucking. So I believe
in going out with, uh, you know,
bringing in a middle act that's,
you know, funny and, and original.
And that's my process to picking
an opener. I use a Joe to Rosa,
Kevin Shay. I'm going to be using this
guy, Todd wrecks up in San Francisco.
These guys, Todd wrecks,
you know, in particular,
no disrespect to those other two
cops, but he really fucking kills.
So I'll let my work cut out
for me that week. But uh, yeah,
I don't want to be that guy.
I don't want to have some guy who just
goes up there with like a lampshade on
his head and stinks. Um, while
these are a lot of questions here,
is this podcast getting too
long? All right. Uh, April,
I've got a question for you. Podcast.
You haven't got a chance to meet
George Carlin. Um, unfortunately, no,
I didn't. I was supposed to meet him. Um,
when was it? February or March,
right before he did his special,
he's supposed to be doing the comedy
magic club down on her Moshe Beach.
And I had just done a spot down there
and they said, hey, he's coming in,
whatever, on a Wednesday or a Tuesday,
he can come down and watch the show
and you can meet him afterwards.
And it was going to be a
dream come true. But, um,
he ended up getting sick. Obviously
his health was failing and, uh,
he ended up canceling so I
never got a chance to meet him,
but I did get a chance to see him and, um,
he absolutely blew me away and it
was actually, it was a long time,
was like 20 years ago before I
was even doing comedy and, uh,
I did at least get to see him
cause I never got to see prior.
So at least I can say that
I saw him and I'm with him.
Passing is really making me want to go
see Don Rickles because, uh, you know,
that guy's in his eighties and he's
still fucking hilarious. And uh,
I don't know. He should,
you know, as a comedian,
I think anybody likes comedy
should see those guys. So No,
I did not get a chance to meet him,
but I did get to see him in person and
obviously as you can see on my page,
he was a huge influence
on me obviously. Um, all,
all right. What are we doing here?
Two more questions and then I'm
going to wrap this fucking thing up.
Number seven, Bill. Um, do you okay.
I actually got a fucking asked
advice here on dating. You know,
I'm fucking not married at 40 and somebody
is asking me advice on relationships.
Okay, you really need to
consider your sources here. Um,
all right. That's like, why don't
you go ask somebody on heroin?
You think math is bad, you know.
Hey man, if you like doing it,
you should fucking do it.
All right, here we go. Bill,
do you think a person deserves more
than one date to determine if there is
chemistry? I recently went
out on a date with a guy.
Turns out he wasn't my type. Well,
there's your answer right there.
But he had a nice personality,
but I feel you should know.
You should feel something immediately.
You're answering your questions. Uh,
it's not like he was my friend to
begin with or will be my friend
that'll have time to grow on me. I feel
very mean and superficial. Oh, whoa.
Okay. There you go. Right there.
There's your first mistake with dating.
When you date, you have to be unbelievably
selfish, unbelievably selfish,
or you're not going to get what you want.
And it's not even being selfish because
if you settle for something that you
don't want, you're not
going to be happy. Okay?
And then you're going to make
the other person miserable.
And that's not fair to the other
person. So fuck that guy. All right.
Fuck him in his nice personality. Hook
them up with another one of your friends.
Say, Hey, I met a guy that I'm not
into, but he has a nice personality.
You know what I mean? That's like a,
that's like watching a TV
show that you don't enjoy,
but you really like the
look of it. The end of it.
You don't like the fucking show. So how
long are you going to be interested?
You know? You know? I don't
know. It's like friends.
I used to watch friends when I lived
in New York City. I was like, God,
look at that apartment, which had
a fucking huge apartment like that,
but I hated the fucking show. So at the
end of the day, I didn't watch the show.
How long can you look up the couch?
All right, question number eight.
This is the final question I built.
Why a while? This is a cheesy question.
I'm a chef so I always ask. Um, and I,
so I always ask and I think
the answer says a lot.
What is your favorite
food slash restaurant? Uh,
what is my favorite
food? I like steak. Um,
and I really liked that steak and
shake. You know, it's got two things.
I really enjoy. Red Meat and shakes. No.
Um, I'm really, I don't know. I like
everything. I would say Italian.
I think Italians make the
best food hands down and uh,
it's absolutely delish and um, you know,
the olive oil and just, you know,
you know what I love about Italians
who really know how to cook.
They know how to add stuff.
Like they, they don't overt.
Like I like explain it. Like
whatever they add enhances the dish.
It doesn't overpower it.
You know what I mean?
Like take like the art of making
pizza somewhere along the line,
the cheese on the pizza rather than
enhancing the taste of the sauce.
The cheese became the focal point. Okay.
I can't explain it. Like it became the
lead in the movie when it was actually,
you know, the, the guy who had two
lines in the movie, it's like, Oh look,
pizza hut. They got it all
over. They got it in the cross.
They got it everywhere.
You just seen a big brick of cheese
and it tastes like fucking shit and you
can't move your bottles afterwards.
That I like Italian food.
I like the olive oil that they cook
with. I just, you know, it's very clean.
You know, you drink that,
you know, it's sip of wine.
As long as you don't eat like, like
you go into the fucking all of garden,
you just feel great. You take
your time, the whole thing.
That's what I like about Italian food
and restaurants, like the whole thing,
the lighting, the ambiance,
everything. Um, so anyways,
with that, my uh, my favorite
restaurant when I was in New York was a,
I used to really, I liked the
lupa. That was my favorite one,
the Mario Batali one and out here in
la, one of the best ones I went to,
I haven't been to a lot out
here. I went to a Motsa,
which is a another Mario Batali one,
but I'm sort of like a hacky restaurant
guy where if they have a show on the
food network, I ended up going to it like,
you know that you know that blonde guy
who wears the sunglasses backwards on his
head. He's actually a
favorite chef of Joe de Rosas.
I forget his fucking name,
but he just goes around to
diners and that type of shit.
And I ate at his restaurant in Sacramento
and it was one of the worst fucking
things I ever went to. He actually
had, I think I talked about it, he had,
he had this Sushi roll that had pork
and French fries in it with some sort of
barbecue sauce and it wasn't
rice. I don't know what it was.
It was some sort of pasty thing. It
was absolutely fucking disgusting.
And it's in Sacramento. Don't
go to it. And a, there you go.
That's the end of the fucking podcast
questions. Um, um, I think that's it.
I think that's it for the week.
Also, I trashed best buy last week,
said I wasn't going to go there anymore
because they had that 15% restocking
fee. Somebody sent me an email about that,
that if you buy something there and you
don't like it and you bring it back,
they still charge you 15% of it to
just stick it back on the shelf.
So some best buy person wrote,
why work at best buy and trust me,
it's necessary. They do it mainly on
computers because when we sell one,
we only make about 20
bucks in profit. Really?
Is that how you keep that big store open?
You make $20 on each
laptop. I don't buy that.
And when someone decides to return it,
if we have to sell it for below cost, no,
you don't.
I've never gone into best buy and
seen a TV or anything that says, uh,
everything there is full price.
What are you talking about?
I don't know. I'm going to give
you the benefit of the doubt. Now.
I'm not gonna give you the benefit
of the doubt cause best buy.
I'm not saying it's you sir,
who wrote this fucking thing,
but you work for an evil fucking place
that put mom and pop fucking places out
of business. Okay. Back in the
day when you return something,
they just returned it.
They put it back in the fucking
box and they stuck it on the shelf.
They didn't charge you 15%. Okay.
That's one of those exploiting
new revenue streams,
new way to come up with extra money to
fuck the customer. I firmly believe that.
I've been in best buy, I've shopped in
best buy, I've never seen any use cds,
any used computers,
everything is brand new. Okay,
so maybe you've got to clarify that.
Is there some sort of off the rack
best buy thing down the street? Uh,
best buy part two. I have no idea. But
uh, I'm still saying fuck best buy.
So why don't you write me a followup.
Okay. I know it was a bit of a cut there,
so explain it further because
I don't get it. So anyways,
that's the podcast for the week.
Thanks to everybody who sent me in
all the Goddamn questions. And, um,
what am I going to say here? Uh,
yeah, I'm going to be at the, uh,
the Improv in Pittsburgh this week
for the love of God. Please come out.
I got a brand new hour that
I'm really proud of and uh,
it's really depressing to, to be at
that Goddamn mall with the stacks,
you know, the poltergeist stacks,
just fucking chimneys there. Okay.
I'm going to the pirates game
Wednesday night. All right.
It'll be me and 30 other
fucking people there.
So you'll be able to see me come up to,
to come up to me and say what's up a
Wednesday night against the Astros.
Um, further news, I'll be in the uh,
comedy works in Denver in
First Week of August. Um,
and what else? I got the Improv in
Miami. I got a bunch of gigs coming up.
I have an upcoming tour, an upcoming,
our special coming out August
23rd on a comedy central.
If I had half a brain and would've said
that at the beginning of this podcast.
I'm am I, new CD is coming out August 3rd.
And I think that's it. Please keep the
questions coming and, uh, and that is it.
Thanks for listening to the podcast.
You guys have yourself a great week.
All right. Take it easy.
[inaudible]
did go away.
you don't
[inaudible] [inaudible] okay.
[inaudible] [inaudible]
[inaudible] oh, make my days. Oh, three
in tech. Go Away. Maceo show
baby in his missed sweet
[inaudible] on your
show. Allow to come back.
[inaudible].